This video is brought to you by wix.
Let's talk about Kanye West.
The years 2009 at the MTV video music
awards killer.
Swift wins an award over beyonce and you
might remember what happened next.
I'll let you finish of the best videos
of all time.
Goes on to apologize and then apologize
and it all gets very confusing.
Fast forward to 2016 and Kanye track
famous features.
This slide
appeal like me and Taylor,
my still as sex.
Why I made that famous,
I made that.
It's famous.
The Internet got mad.
Taylor swift got mad and then audio
comes out that Taylor swift knew about
and even encouraged the song from the
start.
Me and Taylor might still have six.
Yeah,
I mean,
and I really appreciate you telling me
about it.
That's really nice.
Wait,
what?
Well,
this seemingly insignificant example
perfectly explained our current cultural
and political predicament and it all has
to do with a concept from professional
wrestling called,
believe it or not,
if we pay attention to these guys will
be able to better understand what's
going on with these guys.
If we're right,
it might be the case that wrestling
truly can explain everything.
Welcome to the wide world of Kayfabe,
but before we get into it and want to
give a shout out to our sponsor over at
Wix,
if you've ever thought about creating
your own website,
which will give you total creative
freedom to make a professional and
engaging website for any occasion,
we even whipped up a site using their
cool community features so you guys can
vote on what kind of content you want us
to make.
Next.
More on that at the end of the video,
but for now,
back to the show.
So what is it's a term used to describe
the way in which professional wrestling
consists of staged events and
predetermined narratives that are
treated as true.
So even though everyone knows that
wrestling is scripted,
they still treat it like a real athletic
competition.
And even when wrestlers are off the
clock and out of the ring,
they never acknowledged this as this
would constitute the unholy sin known as
breaking Kayfabe.
You never break Kayfabe
the put this commitment to Kayfabe into
perspective.
This would basically be like if Matt
Damon refused to accept his drink at
starbucks,
unless the Barista called out the name
Jason Bourne.
Now wrestling fans aren't idiots.
They of course know that the fights are
scripted and that the wrestlers are
characters,
but it's not the truth of the events
that matter.
It's the story.
It's not true because it's real.
It's true because it's entertaining.
It's still,
hey,
doesn't just apply to any reality show
that may or may not be true.
You as this would make 90 percent of
modern entertainment Kayfabe.
Instead,
Kayfabe refers who entertainment in
which staged events are presented as
real by those producing them and
perceived as real by those consuming
them.
It's kind of like Santa Claus.
Everyone knows he's fake,
but because we're all in on it,
and this time we agree with you Dwayne,
and in case any kiddos are watching
this,
don't be upset while Santa Claus is a
lie,
so is God,
so remove the shackles from your tiny
souls and dare to live a life beyond
good and evil,
but much like John Cena,
Kayfabe didn't stick to just wrestling
for long and in a manner reminiscent of
Dwayne Johnson himself.
Hey,
faith has now infected the entire
entertainment industry and as we'll soon
see our lives and while professional
wrestling is unsurprisingly full of
Floridians.
Another famous floridian has used
Kayfabe in a seemingly unlikely medium
rap music.
Rick Ross,
who is basically the Santa Claus of
Miami,
goes on the phone with June.
The static DC coming,
has built a career on the narrative that
he's a legendary Boston,
the drug game comparing himself to
enthuse kingpins and countless songs.
However,
pictures leaked,
which revealed that the boss with a
belly full of Rosa spent his younger
years as a corrections officer.
So rather than ducking the law,
Rick Ross was enforcing it.
Many assumed this would be the end of
his career.
How do you feel about Boston giving you
an officer Reiki?
I just want to hear it from you.
Maybe I'm worth too much money to even
be side tracked on his copy,
but
it had very little effect.
Ross responded with a fakeness that
would make a French new wave fan proud
about who rosa is.
This about me,
when anywhere I go and I step in the
room,
I put it down.
People know this.
Authentic right here they know is real,
so this go get this money.
Let's make this music and his career has
only grown since Kayfabe can help us
understand this as the fans prefer the
narrative of Ross as a Miami drug
kingpin over the truth of his career in
law enforcement and why would Ross care
what's true and what's not?
As long as he's selling records,
we can see another use of Kayfabe in the
world of Youtube.
Most infamous brothers Bill Paul in a
move that would likely confused Rick
Ross.
The two brothers often engage in a back
and forth beef via youtube videos,
along with making Aaron Carter look
hardcore by comparison.
Thirty four slash seven from this battle
can be best to analyze as a clever use
of Kayfabe to gain the youtube algorithm
to get the brothers and more clicks and
more dollars and just in case Rick Ross
is watching this,
rick,
we will gladly send you a free,
wise crack Hoodie if you post your own
rap video that shuts the Paul's up once
and for all,
and for us did this.
It would make him a shooter,
which is a cafe term for someone who
makes the and wrestling
real.
Before we go on.
It's worth noting how Kayfabe is also
distinct from satire,
while for both the performer
and the audience are in on the joke.
Satire is used precisely to point us
toward the absurdity of the actual truth
rather than create a new one.
For example,
Stephen Colbert engaged in satire on the
Colbert report.
I don't even see race,
not even my own.
People tell me I'm white and I believed
them because I just devoted six minutes
to explaining how I'm not a racist,
as his character was used to exemplify
the absurdity of cable news.
Host Bill O'reilly,
but Info wars host Alex Jones can be
better analyze via Kayfabe.
I'm a pioneer.
I'm an explorer.
I'm a human and I'm coming
is insane.
Claims are always presented in the guise
of political truth and the audience buys
into the narrative.
The cold air and O'reilly example can
help us understand another set of terms
used by Kayfabe faces and heals faces
referred to the good guys in wrestling
and heels are the bad guys,
and while we might outwardly route for
the faces,
the heels are the ones who sell the
tickets.
This can help explain the polarization
of the media.
Heels are where the money is,
so o'reilly and Co had their heel and
Obama.
What President Obama does not understand
is that he has lost all credibility in
matters of security
and now the liberal media has found
their ultimate heal in trump.
What he saying was not true.
Now you might be thinking that if
Kayfabe only applies to the media,
then why should I care?
Well,
we think that Dwayne,
it absolutely does matter because the
terrifying reality is that Kayfabe is an
even better tool for understanding
contemporary politics.
Uh,
Twenty Sixteen New York Times article by
Jeremy Gordon was titled,
is everything wrestling,
which we might rephrase as is our world
becoming one elaborate Kayfabe take Alex
Jones,
while he's known for his subtle
political arguments,
destroy the corrupt them all.
This is their plan people.
These are demons
and stellar advertising campaigns for
legit medical supplements.
Heat recently used to his defense in a
court of law
attorney Randal willhite said Jones is
playing a character on his radio show.
Just claim doesn't change the fact that
his show is considered a new source by
his millions of viewers.
And yes,
it can be fun to play with this persona.
I'm not a Democrat either.
I'm an idealist,
but the pizzagate scandal shows the dark
side of Jones.
His brand of political Kayfabe.
Kayfabe isn't just being used for the
type of fringe media being kicked off
youtube.
It's all over TV news as well.
CNN has acknowledged that their primary
aim is not objective news,
but rather entertainment.
According to a New York Times profile of
CNN,
President Jeff Zucker as Zucker sees it,
his pro trump panelists are not just
spokespeople for a worldview.
They are characters in a drama.
Members of CNNS extended ensemble cast.
Michelle Wolf recently out how much
cable news depends on heels and
constructed narratives.
Watching the host act like the guest
forced his way into the studio is so
compelling,
you almost forget that he was invited
on.
Finally,
the biggest example of political kayfabe
might be the 45th president of the
United States,
Donald J dot trump.
No stranger to reality TV.
Trump is the first politician to fully
embrace the power of Kayfabe.
Trump has made a number of claims that
are clearly untrue.
I know more about isis than the generals
do.
Believe me.
This was the largest audience to ever
witness an inauguration period,
and of course his threats against his
old trend,
Hillary Clinton.
It's just awfully good that someone with
the temperament of Donald trump is not
in charge of the law in our country
because you'd be in jail.
How does much truth behind them as the
beef between stone cold and the rock,
but just like Rick Ross,
his criminal past.
It's the narrative that matters.
Not the facts from maybe especially
extreme in his political Kayfabe,
but politicians across the spectrum use
it just as much.
While the Democrats have been vocal in
their support for fighting against
climate change.
The DNC is also recently backtracked on.
They're banned from taking donations
from the fossil fuel lobby,
but of course this won't stop their
narrative of being the party of
environmentalism.
So why is Kayfabe having a moment?
The most obvious answer is that it
allows people to ground reality in
narrative rather than empirical truth
and who wouldn't want to leave,
and an exciting story full of heroes and
villains and escalating drama.
As Jeremy Gordon said in the New York
Times.
If a story is well told,
if it's history seems consistent than
the machinations,
putting it into place can be temporarily
overlooked or turned into a fun story of
their own and why not?
In the end,
we're all marks for a world we want to
believe it,
and this brings us to our last Kayfabe
vocab term of the day,
mark,
which is a fan who was so excited to
believe,
a narrative that they lose sight of it's
fictional nature and treat it as real
for the mark.
It's not about what is true,
it's about what they want to be true,
and this might be the danger of Kayfabe
when it turns from a principle of
entertainment into a practical
philosophy writer.
Nick Rogers had this to say in the New
York Times.
Kathy isn't merely a suspension of
disbelief.
It his philosophy about truth itself.
It rests on the assumption that feelings
are inherently more trustworthy than
facts.
Hey,
Babes.
Philosophy replaces reason and
objectivity in the favor of emotion and
opinion,
and the most dangerous part of this
world of cafe is that we might not even
realize that we are in fact marks of our
own creation.
And before you go,
be sure to click these links to check
out these videos in which we take down
our competitor website,
clever crevasse,
and they're ridiculous.
Host Gerald and once you're there,
be sure to check out their response to
our response and of course you'll want
to see our response to their response to
our response.
And after that,
you'll want to see our response to their
response to our responses response and
after that,
and you'll want to check out [inaudible]
dot com,
the webpage we made using this week's
sponsor,
wigs,
or teaming up with wigs to redesign our
main site.
But in the meantime,
we thought this would be a perfect
opportunity to show off all the features
wix has to offer right now.
If you head over to our temporary site
link in the description,
you can vote,
uh,
which episode of South Park you want us
to cover on our south part podcast
during the off weeks of the season.
They also have a ton of other useful
features like wigs,
video for the professional trying to
enhance their portfolio or wix stores
for the business owner trying to create
a clean and elegant shop,
no matter who you are.
Wix has the solution for your website
needs.
If you're ready to create your own site,
head to [inaudible] dot com slash go
slash wise crack or click the link in
the description.
Thanks for watching.
And as always,
piece.